disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
disco starter set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below
welcome to the show uh what a big news
weekend and so many different things
happening the kyle rittenhouse case is
uh the trial
is uh into closing arguments and the
jury will be deliberating we may have a
verdict soon we don't yet know uh we're
going to talk about the case related to
the killing of ahmad arbury there's
wacky stuff going on there so many
different things but one of the big
pieces of news news elements i would
even call it breaking um at the very end
of last week and into the weekend is the
indictment of former trump adviser
stephen k bannon who has indeed been
indicted
on contempt for ignoring a subpoena from
the committee investigating the january
6 trump riots and of course wanting to
know steve bannon's role in that given
all of the public statements that he has
made very logical person that they would
want to talk to he ignored the subpoena
he is indicted he is reportedly
surrendering to authorities today
and will be arraigned this is a big deal
and it is yet
another trump associate who uh has been
indicted for different reasons of course
new york times reporting bannon indicted
on contempt charges over house's capital
riot inquiry stephen k bannon a former
top aide to donald trump had refused to
comply with subpoenas from the house
committee investigating the january 6th
attack on congress stephen k bannon a
one-time senior aide to trump was
indicted by a federal grand jury friday
two counts of contempt of congress after
his refusal to provide information to
the house committee investigating what
you and i and reasonable people around
the world know of as the trump riots
bannon who's 67 years old declined last
month to comply with subpoenas from the
committee seeking testimony and
documents the house then voted to hold
mr bannon in criminal contempt of
congress
the house referred the matter to the u.s
attorney's office for a decision on
prosecution
trump has directed former aides and
advisors to invoke immunity and refrain
from turning over documents a justice
department spokesman said bannon was
expected to turn himself into
authorities monday today and make his
first appearance in federal district
court in washington later today
a lawyer for bannon didn't respond to a
request for comment
this is going to be a really really
crazy period of time the department of
justice putting out a statement
um official statement about what they
did stephen k bannon indicted for
contempt of congress two charges filed
for failing to honor house subpoena
um bannon indicted on two counts which i
already told you
one count involving his refusal to
appear for a deposition
another involving his refusal to produce
documents remember that you can subpoena
an individual you can also subpoena
documents he refused uh to show up and
he refused to provide the documents
um
this i don't know that we really need to
read much more of the statement we
continue to see a growing number of
trump associates that have been indicted
we now have steve bannon tom barrack
elliott broidy michael cohen who is down
in his last 10 days or so of his home
confinement sentence michael flynn we're
going to hear from him later in today's
program rick gates paul manafort
george nader george papadopoulos roger
stone and alan weisselberg
quite a uh list of quite a cadre i guess
we would say of characters there
and the question continues to be is this
going to reach donald trump ever
i continue to believe it will not
i continue to believe that the worst
case scenario for trump
would be
um
some kind of business problem i don't
believe this is ever going to reach
donald trump as you will hear in my
comments later on it is now being uh
alleged by one of trump's former press
secretaries that he would hold off the
books meetings
specifically to circumvent records laws
to prevent there being records about
some of his meetings
and
arguably that is a criminal issue but i
just continue to believe that it is not
going to get to him and it is not for
lack of deserving it it is because of
the system and the political forces that
we have at play in the united states so
what is ultimately going to happen with
steve bannon we don't know yet the
arraignment coming later today believed
to be
and this could be there are now
allegations being made
that there are subpoenas going out to
mark meadows trump's then chief of staff
potentially to people like stephen
miller and others if they will also
attempt to
that's the one other thing i wanted to
mention
what steve bannon did is staying loyal
to trump
as the new york times reports trump
directed
bannon and others
not to comply with these requests for
their physical presence and their
requests for documents to be turned over
so bannon is staying loyal to trump now
trump no longer has pardon power
remember trump pardoned uh a number of
different people michael flynn's one of
them who we're going to talk about later
trump doesn't have pardon power anymore
so either
there is a play that trump will
eventually be president again and pardon
them if they stay loyal
that's a long shot it's not that it's
impossible or implausible but it's a
long game you've got to wait years for
to see if trump's even going to run and
then see if he's going to be the nominee
and then see if he's going to win and
then see if he'll pardon you so that's a
very long play
um the other part of it would be they
just believe ultimately they're going to
get out unscathed and that remains to be
seen but we'll see what happens at the
arraignment today and what the next step
is here
maybe there's a timing out aspect maybe
bannon thinks
okay i'm going to get indicted
but in the time that my case will be
pending
the committee will be done
and i might get a slap on the wrist
probably not a big deal but i will have
avoided providing testimony or documents
i don't know okay i don't know what the
legal strategy is but we're going to see
very very soon
later in the show we're going to talk
about
the judge in the kyle rittenhouse trial
and we're going to talk about the mom
wendy written house in the kyle
rittenhouse trial later in the show now
there is now a very wild controversy
involving the defense lawyer
in the case over the killing of ahmad
arbury a trial of multiple officers who
killed ahmad arbury
and that case now is getting attention
because the defense attorney there
made a wild statement in court that he
doesn't want any more black pastors
coming into the court and sitting with
the family
of the victim ahmad arbury now when he
said he doesn't want more black pastors
any sensible person who interprets
language would say so white pastors
would be okay because that sounds racial
and that sounds crazy let's look at the
clip this is attorney kevin i don't know
i don't actually know whether it's
pronounced kevin gau or kevin guff
this case taking place in brunswick
georgia here he is saying he's been
seeing
black pastors coming in to sit with the
family of the victim he doesn't want him
in there take a listen to this this is
crazy
uh and
the idea that we're going to be
seriously bringing these people in to
sit with the victim's family one after
another now these people you could say
that's edgy enough but you don't have to
wonder because he goes and says we can't
have black pastors coming in here
obviously
there's only so many pastors they can
have in fact their pastor's al sharpton
right now that's fine but then that's it
we don't want any more black pastors
coming in here or other
and if you're watching there's a woman
you can actually see wearing a red
blazer who clearly is
instinctive instinctively doing a double
take but then resisting the double take
and just playing it cool because what
this guy is saying is so bonkers
jesse jackson whoever was in was in here
earlier this week sitting with the
victim's family trying to influence a
jury in this case and i'm not saying the
state is even aware that mr sharpton was
in the courtroom i certainly wasn't
aware of it until last night but i think
the court can understand
my concern
about bringing people in who really
don't have any ties to this case other
than political interests now
he is not
wrong about
listen
people are are not connected to the case
and there is a degree to which this can
be used to influence the jury you could
make the argument by the way there's a
militia member who's been sitting in the
courtroom in the kyle rittenhouse trial
we'll get to that later but the idea of
people in the courtroom to influence
juries long-standing topic
the uh
there there's a legitimate point to be
made about
tactics to influence juries
but what is the relevance of black
pastors and as soon as you open that
door you just sound completely off the
wall
and he then apologized but actually says
i've been asked to apologize
now what i love is that the judge
actually says listen
this court meaning you know in in courts
in the u.s when they say the court they
mean the judge the judge is like i
didn't ask you to apologize so the fact
that you've been asked doesn't really
mean anything to me
which is great that the judge did this
judge making a lot more sense than the
one in the written house trial um and
then the apology also includes this
classic thing of
if anyone was inadvertently offended
then i apologize and i've been asked to
apologize what is what a sincere apology
i'm apologizing if anyone was offended
because i've been asked to by others
anyway take a look at this this is the
apology
your honor i've been asked to
address some comments the other day the
court hasn't asked me to do that
whatever you've been asked to do has not
been asked by the court
very well i i will
it's already good here we go
that
if my statements yesterday
were overly broad i will follow up with
a more specific motion on monday what's
funny is the statements weren't overly
broad they were too too narrow that's
actually the problem
if he had said
more broadly
the revolving door of pastors to sit
with the family
may be a technique to influence the jury
or if he had even said
the revolving door of public figures
coming in it wasn't that he was too
broad he wasn't broad enough when you
say the problem is black pastors it's
not a problem of breadth it's a problem
of specificity
putting that in those concerns in the
proper context and my apology to anyone
might have inadvertently been offended
all right
good judge
i actually like this judge um
it can i haven't watched as much of the
of of this trial as the written house
trial
but and this this judge may have done
odd things
but i feel like he's been significantly
more professional and we're going to get
to you know a lot of the very strange
things that were said by the written
house judge uncharged piccolos that
being one of them um i actually like how
this judge has been running the case but
everything about it we can't have black
pastors coming through i've been asked
to apologize the judge is like i didn't
ask you joe that's not kind of neither
here nor there
uh and if anybody i apologize if anyone
was offended it's like the
quintessential non-apology apology but
there it is so things not in the written
house case the judge is more the cartoon
in this trial
it's more the defense attorney so send
me your thoughts on this you can find me
on twitter at deepakman and then after
the break we'll talk about judge bruce
schroeder in the kyle rittenhouse trial
one of our sponsors is disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day the disco starter set
is a simple way to take care of your
skin in three quick steps the face
cleanser stick fights oily skin the
exfoliating face scrub prevents razor
burn and the face moisturizer keeps your
skin hydrated disco can also help with
ingrown hairs dry skin acne and other
things you just need 60 seconds a day
i've been using it for a while now i'm
seeing a noticeable difference maybe you
can even tell
check out disco try out the products for
yourself you will like the results and
you'll get thirty percent off when you
go to
letsdisco.com pacman or just enter the
code pacman the link is down below
welcome back to the show uh i invite you
to subscribe on my website for extra
content every day produced specifically
for our members you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
it takes just a minute or so
and you get instant daily access to the
bonus show it's an additional show we do
every day for our paid members you also
get a commercial free audio feed if you
would prefer you get a commercial free
video feed if you prefer we also have a
members specific
line that you can use to call in when we
do our viewer town halls we did one a
couple weeks ago we've got another one
that i'm going to be announcing very
soon and very strongly i might add
and our members also get priority access
to me during the viewer town hall so all
of those member benefits and more are
available for not a lot of money folks
really not a lot of money and if you
would like an even littler amount of
money
you can use the coupon code better21 to
get a huge discount on my website
joinpacman.com appreciate everybody who
signed up over the last couple of weeks
we've had a nice little influx of new
members all right earlier we talked
about the defense attorney in the trial
over the killing by police of ahmad
arbury
now we are going to talk about the judge
in the kyle rittenhouse trial now i want
to i mean listen i
would this this trial has become so
toxic where if you have anything but a
completely black and white view on
if you have a black and white view on
the matter
half of the audience flips out on you if
you have a gray area view of different
aspects of the trial then everybody ends
up upset for the most part i've already
said i believe that the entire kyle
rittenhouse situation
is a result of educational
parenting and cultural failure in the
united states some of the most
disgusting aspects of gun culture
militia culture
vigilantism etc in the united states and
at the same time i believe that the
facts in the case support a self-defense
a self-defense acquittal
at least
on two of the three main counts in the
case
given
the narrow nature with which those
statutes are written i've already said
it okay so please don't come back to me
on that stuff now i already went out
last week
i went over last week
when the judge bruce schroeder flipped
out on the prosecutor binger in the case
um saying
you were getting dangerously close to
violating the fifth amendment when you
started asking kyle rittenhouse during
testimony about his
uh the timing of when he is first giving
his full version of events you're sort
of going after his right to silence and
implying guilt there uh and the the
judge kind of flipped out on the
prosecutor uh and people have their view
about that now i've gotten a bunch of
emails from people saying david the
judge is fine there's no issue with the
judge at all
first and foremost i would urge folks if
you've not been following the case over
the killing of a mod arbory compare the
role of the judge in the written house
case the role of the judge in that other
case
judges in a way
are like referees in sports and if you
follow sports
if you're talking about the referee
it's a problem okay if the story in a
baseball games in a baseball game
becomes the umpire and their ball and
strike calls it's probably because the
umpire is at least
theoretically doing something wrong
because they're making themselves their
presence known in a basketball game if
the biggest topic of discussion is the
foul calls by referees the referees are
in they're doing too much and they're
playing too big a role it's probably not
good and much the same way in the
written house case
the judge has put himself front and
center to to even give you an example
the judge is so wacky and cartoonish
that people send me for my sound board
for when we broadcast the trial clips of
the judge first of all there's the judge
being obsessed with food and and so for
example by the way how are the calzones
the food is here yeah
let's take a break lunch is here pizza
is here but uh we have subway tomorrow
okay the judge at one point asking the
jury
not to go to the bathroom in the
courtroom like literally do not use the
courtroom as your bathroom whatever you
do make sure you go to the bathroom
somewhere other than the courthouse
and then also the judge seemingly
completely technologically inept
and the defense being able to use in
their favor that the judge is completely
inept at one point referring to pixels
as pickles uncharged piccolos okay so
that's that the judge also has a
reputation for attorneys wanting to
avoid him
uh and in addition to that the
flipping out on the prosecutor
whether or not you believe the content
of the flipping out was justified
many uh legal analysts have said
when the judge flips out on the
attorneys for one side that is known to
influence jurors and thus when the
jurors see the judge flipping out only
on one side
you could make the case that is
influencing the jury now you could say
well maybe the the judge should be
flipping out on one side fine
you send the jury out in order to do it
and um so so that's that now a couple
other things that the judge has done
that are sort of questionable
during cross-examination of a reporter
from real america's voice who is pro
kyle rittenhouse posted pro kyle written
house things to social media
the
um uh prosecutor on cross-examination
started getting into what exactly is
real america's voice
and real america's voice is just a wacky
right-wing channel it's sort of like if
alex jones infowars
reporters are there it would be very
relevant for the jury to understand what
is infowars and when the prosecutor got
to the question about what is the
political leaning of real america's
voice the judge bails out the defense
and says you're not going to ask that
youtube channel yes
do you have your own independent website
that you operate uh i do have an
independent website yes what's that
called
drewhlive.com
what is that
that's my own independent website but is
it like
a news source is it an independent
website
of what type for myself
you
characterized yourself as a professional
commentator what does that mean that
means that i comment on the news
professionally on a daily basis
professionally meaning you're paid yep
who pays you i am employed by real
america's voice right
real america's voice yes what is that
that is a news commentary breaking news
uh website they have their own apps
and uh yeah a website
other than getting paid by real
america's voice do you get paid by any
other source to do your professional
commentating no
is your drew h live website part of real
america's voice no
the things that you post on your website
drew h live do you also share those with
real america's voice
um depending on
what's going on where i'm at
um but this is unrelated to what
happened in kenosha because i was not
employed by real america's voice at the
time that's something that's happened
since then yes
and uh does real america's voice have
any sort of
political
bias or agenda or anything like that
it goes to the bias of the witness your
honor
uh the
highest in what respect
so anyway to cut to the end the um the
judge doesn't allow that to be asked
about and again it's like if the witness
were alex jones and you're not allowed
to inquire about what infowars is it's
absolutely wild
and then lastly a very strange comment
which some are saying is a political
comment
one day they were having asian food
asian food as the judge says and the
judge made what some are calling a
political comment by saying hopefully
the food's not stuck on one of those
boats in long beach harbor alluding to
this supply chain controversy and of
course they're in wisconsin folks so
it's completely unnecessary comment but
it's a joke that goes some argue to
political bias uh let's hope for one
o'clock i don't know the uh hopefully
asian food isn't coming it's on isn't on
one of those boats in long long beach
harbor
[Laughter]
now even if he doesn't mean thanks to
biden it's on one of those boats it's
off color and it's not appropriate and
the judge is very very wacky so i my
feeling is
while on the major
charges
not guilty follows the facts
the entire thing seems like a foregone
conclusion and the judge seems to be
very much so helping that along so
that's the judge let's now go to the mom
one of my
concerns when it comes to the kyle
rittenhouse trial
has been that whatever the legal outcome
the right-wing media is going to make
this kid a hero or a martyr and what i
mean by that is if he's acquitted he
will be made a hero and it will be
a bellwether example
of how you can choose to go out and be
an armed vigilante
even if you've got the gun illegally
you can create a situation in which you
end up fearing for your life not denying
maybe he did right you create a
situation
and you go free
and he is going to if he is acquitted be
held up as a hero by the right when in
reality this is a failure of parenting
it's a failure of culture it's a failure
of so many different things
if he's found guilty on any of the
counts he does any jail time whatever
he will be then seen as a martyr
and
the problem here is thinking that he did
something good he shouldn't have been
there he was carrying the gun illegally
after killing one person he didn't even
try to leave he ended up killing a
second person and shooting a third
person
so of course in the lionization of kyle
rittenhouse right in the middle of the
trial
sean hannity decides to interview the
mom wendy rittenhouse she agrees to go
on fox news and it's as bad as you can
imagine
um let's just start somewhere the topic
of white supremacy comes up and sean
hannity says i've seen no evidence at
all that would suggest he's even maybe a
white supremacist
let's take a look at that when the then
candidate now president of the united
states
and other elected officials
that don't know anything about your son
refer to him as a white supremacist
i have yet to see any evidence
whatsoever
that he is such a person
now
i don't know if kyle rittenhouse is a
white supremacist i've not mentioned it
during the trial and i just don't know
but kyle rittenhouse was photographed at
a bar
holding up that upside down okay symbol
now often associated with white
supremacy so it might not be definitive
might not be definitive evidence but
hannity's saying there's no evidence
it's a very weak comment
part of the this kid's a victim
he's a great kid all of his beliefs are
great
and he's a hero for what he did with the
guns
kyle
written house's mom by the way is a big
fan of the judge now it's not a big
surprise for those saying the judge has
just called balls and strikes and isn't
helping one side or the other
if the mom felt
the judge was not useful to them she
would not be saying the judge is great
okay so big surprise she likes the judge
take a look
the judge is very fair
um people that i talk to that lives in
kenosha
all their lives they told me that judge
schroeder is a very fair drudge and he
doesn't allow no nonsense
in his courtroom
not a surprise not a surprise the
judge's decisions have been to the
extent that he's a factor at the trial
his decisions have been mostly good for
the defense
then the topic came up
of when
kyle rittenhouse was being
directly examined by his own defense
attorneys he started crying the images
in the video have gone viral i've not
commented on was it real or not were the
tears real was it stage whatever i have
no idea
she says uh well he was heart she was
heartbroken by that
that's your son
how did that make you feel
it just
i just broke down with with kyle crying
like that
it made me feel
heartbroken
sad
and i wanted to just go up there and
just hug him
and tell him it would be okay
this is part of
turning the kid into a hero
via
turning the kid into a victim that's
part of it
um here's the real cherry on top
would kyle do it all over again in the
same way
and his mom says
he probably would um have you and your
son discussed
whether or not if he had to do it over
again he would go into a situation like
that
with kyle
i know him and he probably would do it
again because that's the type of person
he is
not even and i would encourage him not
to go
even if it's self-defense this is a
tragedy to be avoided at all cost
two people are dead it has ruined our
lives look at what we are now embroiled
in i would tell him not to go kyle
yeah he'd probably do it again they've
learned nothing it's not like he went
and saved 10 people so it was worth it
it's not like he went and threw his
providing
medical
as he was supposedly there to do
people survived who wouldn't have
it's he he just went and people died and
now he's in the middle of a trial and he
would do it all again sadly i think
she's right that's the saddest thing and
you know the the right loves to talk
about the importance of parenting this
is a total parenting failure and the
interview is proof of that now one last
thing i want to say about the mom and i
want to say it carefully
there are people who have written to me
and they said david
the mom isn't cognitively there
if you listen to the interviews and the
way she talks and you see her presence
in in the courtroom some she's disabled
cognitively and everybody should give
her a break
i don't know where people are getting
that
i don't i've i've i researched it
because eight or ten people wrote to me
about that
is it her appearance that you're basing
that on i found nothing about the mom
being cognitively limited in any way i
don't know if the com comments are
classist in some way i have no idea what
her level of education is i believe
she's a nurse so to some degree she's
educated uh i don't know anything about
that and for me it's not playing a role
in analyzing the things that she's
saying so there's the interview with the
mom not particularly surprising as far
as the content and we'll have some of
these clips on our instagram at david
pakman show where you you can also
comment and let me know what you think
of that interview
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's get to uh two stories
that are just um
there it's not beyond parody they seem
almost beyond reality but unfortunately
they are very very real
remember back on january 6th when the
trump rioters who
are trump supporters presumably
because they're they're writing for
trump to remain president started
chanting hang mike pence and of course
hang mike pence was related to
mike pence
being
asked to
being by some expected to do
something even though it's not exactly
clear what he could do he couldn't
actually do anything
to delay
the counting of the votes on january 6th
in congress
donald trump in a now revealed interview
with abc reporter jonathan carl which is
being released as part of the release of
jonathan carl's new book we have audio
we're going to play it for you
donald trump defends his supporters
chanting hang mike pence saying listen
pence was safe he wasn't actually in
danger
and the supporters were right to be
angry because the election was stolen
again going to the previous reports that
trump was furious with pence demanding
pence do something to keep him in office
which pence couldn't do
so again another story verified um let's
go to the audio here is the interview
from march of uh this year take a listen
to this were you worried about him
during that siege were you worried about
no i thought he was well protected and i
i had heard that he was in good shape
no because uh i had heard he was in very
good shape but
but no you heard those chants that was
terrible he was you know the
he could have oh the people were very
angry
so jonathan carl says the hat the chance
the hang mike pence was terrible and
trump says well people were angry
and that they were legitimately angry
because it's it's common sense
it's common sense
that
you're supposed to protect how can you
if you know a vote is fraudulent
right how can you pass on a fraudulent
vote
to congress
so there's like
three different things there first of
all
notice how they mention common sense
when they can't really give you
empirical reasoning or data to justif
it's common sense it's common sense when
i was in a jury room thinking back to
you know all these trials we've been
covering when i was in the jury room and
we were supposed to decide whether
something was self-defense on the basis
of the way the law was written
four
two to four of the six jurors insisted
it's common sense it was self-defense
rather than what does the law say so sel
commons common sense comes out often
when they can't actually explain their
positions um and then again how can if
you know a vote is fraudulent trump says
how can you pass a fraudulent vote onto
congress whatever your belief about that
which trump never demonstrated there was
anything fraudulent whatever your belief
about that is
pence did not have the ability or
authority
to prevent the election from being
certified for joe biden common sense
would be
trump is on trial in multiple
jurisdictions that would be common sense
here
so then basically just as interestingly
this is crazy what trump is saying he's
defending the chance of hang mike pence
because the anger at pence was
legitimate as trump sees it and pence
was safe
per trump's opinion on that
the question is brought to republican
senator john barrasso and he's given the
opportunity to criticize donald trump's
defense of the chance of hang mike pence
and barrasso doesn't do it if you need
another signal
about whether the republican elected
officials are still standing in line
behind donald trump uh
and and um uh
supportive at least publicly of trump
it's this take a look at this he's given
the opportunity to criticize trump for
this and he doesn't finally i want to
ask you about president trump as you
know john carl our chief washington
correspondent had an interview with
president trump be released this week
where the president seems to defend
those who are saying hang mike pence on
january 6th you want to show it
does were you worried about him during
that siege were you worried about no i
thought he was well protected and i i
had heard that he was in good shape no
you heard those chants that was terrible
he was you know the
he could have well the people were very
angry we're saying hangman because it's
it's common sense how can you if you
know a vote is fraudulent
right how can you pass on a fraudulent
vote
to congress
so he says hang mike pence is common
sense
can your party tolerate a leader who
defends murderous chance against his own
vice president
well
well let me just say the republican
party is incredibly united right now and
it's because of the policies
administration and i think the more that
the so first response is to say this
administration is bad bidens and so it's
united the party democrats and the press
becomes obsessed with president trump i
think the better it is for the
republican party president trump brings
lots of energy
to the party he's raised
force elections are about the future not
the past and that's what we saw in
virginia and all across the country and
the republican policies and the trump
policies of a strong economy and
american energy not begging vladimir
putin to produce more oil which is what
joe biden is doing
remember the question is is it a problem
that
trump is saying
it's okay to say hang mike pence and so
far we've got no answer from john
barrasso
those are policies that we're going to
continue to run on in the future so you
have no problem with the president
saying
hang mike pence as common sense
i was with mike pence in the senate
chamber
during january 6th and what happened was
they quickly got vice president pence
out of there certainly a lot he's
basically saying the same thing pence
wasn't really in danger so it's okay
it's not a big deal lester then they
removed the senators i believed he was
safe the whole time um i didn't hear any
of those chants i don't believe that he
did either and vice president pence came
back
into the chamber that night and there's
no so he's not even accepting that the
chance took place which is fascinating
so listen that is really something else
and remember that no republicans
disputed the results of their votes on
the same ballot you had a bunch of
senators and then the trump biden
election the same people saying the
trump biden ballot count can't be
trusted
said nothing about their election count
uh only trump the voting process was
legitimate other than trump biden they
only messed with those ballots these
people are disingenuous they don't
actually believe it but they are
unwilling unwilling
to actually criticize donald trump and
much of the reason is trump still has
power at least for now
trump may continue to have power beyond
2022 trump may be the nominee in 2024
and trump may be
maybe president again and none of them
are willing to call him out even when he
says well
it made sense that the people were mad
and pence was safe so hang mike pence
not really a big deal is there any
example from history
of a president
not denouncing chance from his own
followers
to hang the vice president are there
even examples from history of a
president whose followers chanted hang
the vice president and now that i'm
aware of not that i'm aware of all right
we have shocking new claims
that are coming at a convenient time for
the person making them in order to sell
books of course they always wait until
it's time to sell books donald trump's
brief press secretary stephanie grisham
is now making the claim
that donald trump deliberately had off
the books meetings
to circumvent records laws in other
words normal president
has meetings
that are on the books
with rare exceptions for very narrow and
specific national security reasons
and there is a record of the fact that
the meetings took place there's records
of what was discussed if the things were
classified there is some version that
does not violate classified uh
restrictions on topics or documents that
are brought up or whatever the case may
be that's that's how things normally are
very rare exceptions for specific
national security reasons rare very rare
the allegation from stephanie grisham
which she made on cnn we're going to
play it for you in a moment
is that merely to avoid there being
records of meetings that donald trump
was having
he had the records the meetings off the
books and of course in the context of
trump trying to prevent january 6th
investigators from getting records about
who he met with uh
and others are in trump's circle
supporting trump doing that there's a
second layer we have to now contend with
if you believe stephanie grisham which
is even if the meetings for which there
are records
are accounted for to the investigators
trump allegedly was having certain
meetings off the books anyway so there
are no records for some of these
meetings here is stephanie grisham
explaining it to jim acosta on cnn
wanting to keep hundreds of pages of
documents out of the hands of the
january 6 committee um
but you think that there are some off
the book meetings uh some in the
residence of the white house that
lawmakers may want to look into i mean
stephanie you you know that residence as
well as
most ex officials of that administration
what goes on behind closed doors there
absolutely uh lots of meetings take
place in the residence where you know i
mean i'm hoping that they're looking at
call logs but i i have a feeling even
sometimes things weren't uh put into
call logs but a lot of meetings took
place because the president at the time
was so paranoid of leaks that a lot of
our meetings took place in the residence
number one so he could keep track of who
was in there and if it leaked out
he would try to you know figure that out
but number two so that it was very much
kept off the books and documents
anything that was written down could
probably be thrown in the trash where
people can't you know come and retrieve
them to put into the archives so that
happened quite a bit and i'm sure the
select committee is aware of that and is
looking into that um mark meadows was
one towards the end who was definitely
helping to um plan those meetings so i
think that mark meadows should be spoken
to i think he will stall so um
you know i i'm with you guys on
i'm so glad
that she has held on to that information
until
right now perfectly timed to sell copies
of her book i get it okay i get it
um but this fits with everything else we
know about donald trump uh guy who
claimed he would have the most what was
it like open and transparent
administration out of anybody or
something like that
and just think like
what we know about the presidency of
trump is bad enough
there are now things coming out that we
are learning and they're really bad and
then there's a whole other layer of
things we probably will never know
because of things like this there are no
records or whatever the case may be
um remember that there's also the
incredible double standard or hypocrisy
that one of the main reasons that donald
trump said hillary clinton was unfit to
be president of the united states was
she violated the presidential records
act because of the private email server
and on and on and on and of course we
find out that many people around trump
were also using private email but then
we now find out all of the different
ways in which donald trump either wants
to prevent records from being given even
to investigators legitimately demanding
them and even went out of his way to
prevent records from being created in
the first place so it's all toxic it's
all insane it's all wacky but it's
what's going on and just imagine if this
guy gets back into power in 2024
how much worse it's going to be
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
pakman show so we're continuing to
follow sort of two stories that are
coming together one is this brewing
civil war within the republican party
told you last week just as one data
point 13 republicans voted in favor of
joe biden's uh 1.2 trillion dollar the
eventual 1.2 trillion dollar stimulus
package 13 republicans crossing party
lines to vote in favor trump republicans
immediately demanding the removal of
those 13 republicans just one data point
in this growing civil war and we've
looked at others that's one story which
we're going to talk about today the
second is what's going to happen in 2024
in terms of trump running versus not
running in the relationship with mike
pence etc well we have one story that
brings both of these two elements
together uh one of the former white
house communications directors under
donald trump alyssa farah
was on cnn over the weekend
and said number one
mike pence is now ashamed of donald
trump
and number two she believes that pence
or someone else like ron desantis or
others
are going to run against trump in 2024
in the republican primary if trump runs
and we'll try to go after trump's voters
now there's so much to talk about here
so many different aspects to this that
are important but let's first look at
what exactly alyssa farah said when she
appeared on cnn um and we we know
from the trump side his contempt for
mike pence is very clear uh telling him
don't be a uh p the p word i don't know
if i can say it or not um with regard to
his behavior on january 6th and not
stopping the certification of the vote
which of course mike pence had no
authority to do
uh defending as i told you earlier the
calls to quote hang mike pence on
january 6 from his own supporters we
know trump's ire towards pence here is
the first indication direct indication
that we have from someone who would know
that pence is ashamed of trump as well
let's listen
so why did pence talk to him
after this i mean that was something as
just an observer you know here
you have protesters chanting hang mike
pence and all this going on and yet they
still talked after
the insurrection why is that what do you
make of that so to the best of my
knowledge i think pence by default is
somebody who's very deferential to both
the chain of command and the institution
of the presidency and i think he would
always take a call from donald trump he
would always take a meeting if one was
requested from him i think that must
have been those must have been very
awkward and tough conversations
i've always known mike pence to be a
person of deep character and conviction
so i don't doubt that in those private
communications he communicated how bad
that was and how inappropriate was but
not for him but for the country um but
yeah i can't imagine that was a
comfortable conversation and i think
that you're gonna see a bit more
distancing as time goes on look there's
there's aspects of the record they did
together that i know pence is proud of
but i know he is ashamed of that day
he's ashamed of how the pres former
president conducted himself wow so we
expect that donald trump will run again
for 2024
do you think that pence will run against
him so i think he will and i'm saying
this with no knowledge outside of you
know any special knowledge but it's
informed speculation let's be honest i
do think that um there's this belief
that people are just going to clear the
field for trump i actually think some
folks are teeing up to run i think pence
could be one of them i think desantis
might be one of them i think mike pompeo
is looking at
a political team and what that could
look like and it's a good thing for the
party a coronation of donald trump would
be the worst thing both for the party
but more importantly for the country
interesting we're going to need to have
out these debates on the stage by the
way of was the election stolen and
that's going to be a tough question for
some of these folks to answer because
somehow that would be a fascinating
debate to see republicans have in the
primary in 2024. really towed the line
of the big lie um so i'd love to see
some folks run who are going to
acknowledge the truth and the reality
and actually just try to win over more
voters so you think so you do think from
your
you know from your um
perch which is a good perch because you
used to be press secretary for pence you
think he will from your
your view what makes you think that and
what do you think that would be like
because all we have seen from pence and
trump is pence being deferential to
trump and being a loyalist to trump what
do you expect i think that pence knows
he's uniquely positioned in that he can
tout the record and the things that so
so this is where she goes off the rails
americans are still
they still wish you were in office the
74 million people who voted for trump
but without a lot of the downside now
great okay so let's let's discuss this
um
first of all
this is great from the standpoint of
hurting republicans by having them hurt
themselves by fighting amongst
themselves i've said before
it's really
terrible it's sad it's embarrassing it's
humiliating that democrats have so
little going for them that essentially
they have to hope
that the right just damages itself
and that's a disastrous place to be in
it means you have very little going for
yourself it's an extremely low standard
but to the extent that we want the right
to fight amongst itself what alyssa
farah is pointing out here is fantastic
pence ashamed of trump trump has furious
repents whatever the case may be
they may run against each other they may
be going after the same voters that's
great
but one thing you have to realize from a
practical standpoint is anybody
supporting donald trump today
is not voting for mike pence in 2024
unless something radical happens and
what i mean by that is that the people
still supporting donald trump and by
supporting him i don't just mean i voted
for him and i probably would again i
mean the people still supporting trump's
message today of the election was stolen
and it was all rigged and pence was bad
and he did an unpatriotic thing and all
these different things
you were so
uh aggressively committed to the whole
cult if that's your belief that you're
not voting for mike pence in 2024 in a
republican primary so the idea that
there's so much to fight over in terms
of swaying voters in 24 i think alyssa
farah is wrong on that but i'd love to
see them try because it will damage
themselves but here's the second part of
it
alyssa farah talks about
pence can go and run
on the record of trump pence on the
accomplishments
what is she talking about what what on
see this is where i continue to say just
because we come across a republican that
says like one or two reasonable things
like joe biden really won
liz cheney is an example these are still
outrageous republicans who believe crazy
things like pence has a record to run on
um it's completely delusional first of
all to think that mike pence
has a political future of any serious
kind in the united states he served as a
sort of shield arguably to the most
incompetent president in history donald
trump to i guess help him win some
religious voters and and i think he
probably did do that particularly in
2016. um and now those very aggressive
trump voters hate pence because pence
didn't help trump steal
the 2020 election
who is pence's constituency really uh
because if you if if you believe it was
stolen then you believe pence did
something wrong by not taking it for
donald trump
and if you don't like trump you've
bailed on trump long ago and you
probably realize that there are no
accomplishments to speak of so it's kind
of like a jeff sessions type situation
so very interesting to hear from melissa
farah i think she's way off on the idea
of mike pence having an independent
political future we have another one of
these i still consider these sad stories
but they could be instructive they could
be wake-up calls a police officer from
san francisco
who was suspended he was on leave for
refusing the covet vaccine has died of
covet
um i am i am sick of watching people
throw their lives away
optionally
statistically speaking
and at the same time contributing to
this sense of doom of are we ever going
to get out of this this is a horrible
story california police officer dies of
covid while on leave for missing
vaccination deadline now
the requirements work
as a friday 97.2 percent of the san
francisco police department were in
compliance with the city's vaccination
mandate but
we have a specific story here
of a san francisco police officer who
was on leave for missing the city's
covet vaccination deadline
has died after testing positive for the
coronavirus according to a police union
representative and the officer's wife
we're talking about officer jack nice
who had been on the force 17 years the
police department said in a statement on
his facebook page announcing his death
nice served in a variety of assignments
throughout his career adding that he is
survived by many friends co-workers and
family members chief bill scott
confirmed to nbc news that nice who was
described as a widely respected
colleague died saturday at age
47 scott declined to comment about cause
of death
nice's wife melissa nice did say to the
san francisco chronicle that he had
tested positive for the virus last
tuesday his symptoms became so serious
that she called an ambulance to take him
to a hospital on saturday
she declined to say whether he was
vaccinated against covid and said he was
by his side said she was by his side
when he died
um folks
statistically speaking statistically
speaking vaccinated people die
vaccinated people die statistically
speaking
this is someone who would have had a
much milder case if vaccinated the
belief is that he's unvaccinated because
he was on leave for not meeting the
vaccination requirements now one could
say david maybe he was vaccinated but he
didn't want to have to provide the
dystopian 1984 proof of his vaccine to
the department so he was suspended for
that
that's possible and it strikes me as
extraordinarily unlikely these are not
stories to gloat about these are stories
where
if we learn something from them
maybe we can get something useful out of
them but these are sad stories i
continue to see these as sad and it is
another person statistically speaking
growing our sense of doom are we ever
going to get out of this pandemic and
throwing their life away and it is
really sad i mean think about it
he signed up to be a police officer
you could be stabbed as a police officer
you could be shot as a police officer
etc
but a tiny needle
they're not going to do that
they're not going to do that so another
one of these stories and i hate to see
it i know there are people in the
audience who write to me and say david i
have no sympathy for these people i have
no empathy for the
loved ones that are left behind i do
maybe it's my personal flaw i do
uh but the real problem is are we ever
going to get out of this if we continue
to see this sort of uh resistance
horrible horrible stuff
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
you can call anytime you want i got a
great voicemail from a very nice older
lady she says she's an older lady she
wants me to know the older folks aren't
all wacky conspiracy theories spreading
trumpists she also praises
my occasional pronunciation of the
animal dog take a listen to this
hi david this is anne darcy thank you
for recently gracing us with the correct
pronunciation of the word dog
anyway i'm calling to see if you can
give a shout out to or some validation
to your older listeners yes we are not
all science denying use mac watching
trumpets as portrayed in popular media
thank you for clearly presenting
facts and knowledge keep up the good
fight thank you
absolutely ms darcy is completely
correct we have listeners
that i know of progressive listeners
into their 90s
and um that's a fantastic thing when we
say statistically
the disinformation is coming from 65
plus or when we say statistically on
facebook it's older folks we share
just because we make a statistical
statement doesn't mean i would wrongly
think that of every one of our older
viewers
no doubt about it and i appreciate the
clarification we have a great bonus show
for you today
what actually came from the un climate
summit what happened there we're going
to talk about it
we will talk about a bipartisan bill
that would force big tech to offer
algorithm free feeds and search results
we used to have this you used to be able
to just see your twitter feed in reverse
chronological order no algorithmic
elements at all
um we're going to talk about that and
then lastly
things are not looking good in germany
from the standpoint of covid
um
and this could be what's coming for the
united states i i know i know it's like
we're again we're doing it again
um it's not looking good in germany i'm
gonna talk about that my brother
actually just landed in germany this
morning for work and um
let's just say he made sure to get his
third dose before going over there so
all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com you'll get instant access
and i look forward to you joining me
then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the disco
starter set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below